Thank you for the birthday wishes. Let's
uh let's bring somebody else up. Shahid,
how you doing?
>> How you got Roick?
>> I'm pretty good. Pretty good. Thank you.
>> So, I see you're watching the guy there
with false prophecy. If a prophet speaks
the truth, he has to be fully truthful.
And if he is given false prophecy, then
he's not a true prophet,
>> right?
>> Can you apply that to the Bible?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So
>> you apply that
>> as here in the Bible one when he became
king he was 22.
>> You apply that to the Quran, right?
>> No, no. I'm applying the same thing to
uh the Bible.
>> All right. So I got to show you I got to
show you the false prophecy in Islam
first and then we could go to the
>> Okay. Uh is it from the Quran or the
Hadith?
>> It's from the Hadith.
>> Okay. Do you know that there's
fabrication in there?
>> Yeah, this one is Sai Muslim in your in
the second most authentic book just
behind Bkar.
What do the scholars say about Sah
Muslim aside from Sahib Bkari is the
first authentic book of hadith.
>> Exactly. So I'm giving you something
from
>> the second book of hadith. Do you know
that there's fabricated hadith in that
book?
>> Yeah. But this this one's not a
fabricated.
>> I will read the hadith. Let me see what
you're speaking about and let me hear
what the false prophecy is.
>> All right. Subhan Allah. All right.
>> Oh, you're praising Jesus as God. I like
that. I like that.
>> No, I'm prais I'm praising Jesus. He's
the real Allah.
>> No.
You like that?
>> I'm pretty quick, man. I'm pretty quick.
>> I love that.
>> Thank you. All right. So, we go to Sah
Munah.
>> Yep.
>> That's one thing we That's one thing we
Muslim don't make joke about the prophet
Isaiah. So,
>> yes, y'all do
>> you make all the jokes you want.
>> Yeah. Some Some of you guys put Jesus in
in a clown suit on a cross and say that
you say disgusting things about him. So
which guys which guys is that?
>> Well, you you wouldn't know these guys,
but these are guys that I see every day
online.
>> Okay. So then they're, you know, they're
wishy-washy. They're wishy-washy Muslims
or maybe
>> they're No, they're true Muslims.
They're they're real Muslims to the
core.
>> Okay. All right. Let's get to the um the
meat of the matter here.
>> All right. Gotcha. Asked about,
by the way, what would you say the last
hour is?
>> The last hour is the beginning of the
judgment day. I agree with you. Okay,
so this is uh Sahi Muslim 2952.
Uh I mean I'm just trying to put it on
the screen. Sorry, hold on one second.
Um
well, by the way, do you know that three
doctors in yesterday became Muslims? Two
or two in Japan and one in Kashmir, I
think. doctors. They took the shahada
yesterday on the on the I think one was
on um Hashim sites on the talk show. A
doctor from Kashmir some I think Kashmir
or somewhere from the Indian Peninsula.
He took shahada.
>> Okay. You know the right side is on the
right side. This is
>> 295. Bring it up.
>> Brother, you're talking over me, man.
Can you not talk over me?
>> Okay. You're saying you can't see it?
>> It's very small.
Is this better?
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> Let me uh Let me actually do this and
try to make it. Let's do this. Let's do
I don't have a bigger. Okay, I'll just
uh do this like this. How about that?
That better?
>> Last.
>> All right. So, it says
>> Anas reported that a person asked
Allah's messenger as to when the last
hour would come. They're asking about
judgment day. He had in his presence a
young boy of the Ansar who was called
Muhammad. Allah's messenger said,
>> "Can you read the beginning lives?"
>> The beginning.
>> I just read the beginning.
>> No, that's not the beginning. Go back to
the top.
>> I just read the top and I read the
beginning.
>> Yeah. Read from the top there.
>> I already did. Are you listening?
>> Yeah.
>> So, I already read that. You just
probably wasn't listening. I just read
the read that. So, now I'm going into
it. Here it is again. Anas reported that
a person asked Allah's messenger.
>> Yes.
>> As to when the last hour would come. Did
you hear me read the beginning now?
>> All right. I heard that. Yes.
>> He had a in his presence a young boy of
the Ansar who was called Muhammad.
Allah's messenger said, "If this young
boy lives, he may not grow very old till
the last hour coming to you." that look
that young boy lived and died and the
last hour did not come. So this is a
false prophecy by Muhammad.
>> Boy,
>> so you see the false prophecy.
>> No, that's not um a false prophecy. What
he's trying to say?
>> Yeah. Tell us what he's trying to say.
So this a hadith is saying to a young
boy a young boy the time of age that he
will die that is referring to the
average time of age a human being will
live to
>> brother it doesn't say anything like
that let's let's be let's not let's not
play with the text it says they asked
when the last hour would come and
Muhammad says if this young boy lives he
won't grow very old until he sees the
last hour coming.
>> Okay. Did the boy a young boy live?
>> Of course.
>> Okay. At what age did he die?
>> I I don't know. But he was around an
age. You know who?
>> You have to you have to you have to
understand. You see this there's
something which you you brothers don't
understand.
>> He said that the that the last hour
would come in that time frame. If he
lives long enough, he'll see it.
>> Yeah. So referring to if he died off, he
wouldn't see it because he died.
that age.
>> This is referring to the age that
everyone will be living because
>> it doesn't it doesn't say anything about
everyone.
>> I know it says this young boy if this
young boy lives whose name is Muhammad
he won't grow very old until the last
hour comes to you. So it's supposed to
happen in his lifetime.
>> No, it's it will happen in everyone's
lifetime. That's what he's trying to
say. That the age of the young boy.
There's no way you and I can have a
conversation cuz you are way too
dishonest.
>> Take care of yourself. Go do a lap
around the Cabba, man. Off the stage.
You're too dishonest. You're too much of
a liar. You can't stay here. Adnan, how
you doing?
>> Yeah, I'm good. How are you?
>> I'm pretty good. I'll convert to Islam
if you can show me that Muhammad me is
mentioned by Jesus. Man,
>> no. No. I'm going to solve this problem
another way. So, you so you believe in
John 17:3, right?
>> Did you hear what I said? I know. But do
you believe in John 17:3?
>> You said you know. So you So you're
openly ignoring what I just said.
>> Ignoring what?
>> Ignoring what? What I just said?
>> That Jesus mentioned Muhammad.
>> Yeah. Your Quran says Jesus mentioned
Muhammad. I'll convert to Islam if you
can show me where Jesus mentioned
Muhammad.
>> So you're saying that the Quran says
Jesus mentioned Muhammad. Yeah. Where
does the Quran says that?
>> In chapter 61:6. It says that Jesus came
confirming the Torah that came before
him and came with glad tidings of a
messenger to come after him whose name
is Ahmed.
>> So you're saying you're saying that the
the the Canaanite Bible, the canon has
got the complete account of all what
Jesus has said, right?
>> Did you say the Canaanite Bible?
>> The canon, what you call the canon, the
four gospels.
>> I just said that I will convert to Islam
if you can show me where Jesus said this
or mentioned Muhammad.
>> Yeah, that's what I'm getting to. So
what I'm saying is do you believe the
four gospels
is the entire account for of Jesus' life
whatever he said. Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> So whatever he said to the Roman the
child on the street or whatever is all
included in that
>> everything in regards to Jesus ministry
and what he taught and his revelations
that he gave is it
>> no that's what I'm saying that's the
word of God. That's the God for you. So
whatever whatever he said to the
shopkeeper or whatever he said to the
gatekeeper or the child on the street
that's the word of God. So everything is
accounted in th those gospels.
>> Can you So can you show me where Jesus
said this or not?
>> No that's what I'm saying. So something
that Jesus said is is might not be
accounted in those gospels. That's what
I'm saying.
>> I know I know that's what you're saying.
So can you account for them anywhere
else? So what I'm trying to say to you
is not everything is accounted in those
four gospels.
>> I got that. He would have said that.
It's not the gospel does not the four
gospel accounts don't account for
everything he said. I heard you.
>> Yeah.
Something that can account for him
saying this.
>> Uh no. We have been told through the
Quran that he said that. I'm saying that
it is not accounted in the four gospels.
>> It's unverifiable is what you're saying,
right? unverifiable for you but for for
us Quran is sufficient for you it's
unver okay when you say for me that
means that you are actually able to
verify it I can't so I need you
>> you go no you go and verify that you
have to the process I need my brother
slow down
>> show me where Jesus said this verify it
for me since I can't that means you can
verify it for me where did he say it
show me
>> I have to trust the process I have to
trust that prophet Muhammad was a true
prophet and That's my process.
>> Well, okay. So, so notice this. You just
acknowledge without saying the words,
but what you just acknowledged is that
you can't verify it either.
>> You're just going on you're just going
>> because I trust that uh what Prophet
Muhammad said is the word of God just
like you say that what is in those four
gospels is the word of God.
>> Well, no, it's not the same. It's not
the same. The reason why those can go is
the word of God.
>> Right now I'm have to muzzle you. Please
don't interrupt me while I'm talking.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> The reason why I believe that the gospel
is the word of God is because of the
resurrection of Jesus. His words have
been proven. His statements have been
proven. Uh his prophecies have been
fulfilled. That's why I believe the
gospel contains the word of God. You on
the other hand believe in blind faith.
You're just trusting, oh, you know what?
Well, Muhammad has to be a prophet, so
I'm going to believe that Jesus said
this somewhere. But you can't verify
this, right? Whenever Jesus says, "Hey,
this is written in the prophets," I can
go and find that. You can't go and find
what Muhammad said, Jesus mentioned,
right?
>> So, you saw Jesus resurrecting. Yeah.
>> Get off my stage. What a man. What a
breed of people who waste time. A breed.
You guys are the same breed of people.
Insane. Oh my gosh. One after the other.
Now, for real, guys, for the Muslims
that's watching and listening, I hope
that you guys saw what just happened.
And when I say that, I hope that you saw
what happens. I don't mean that I hope
that you are watching because I know
you're watching. I hope that you saw
what happened. Like you understood
what doesn't work when you want to give
dawa. And we're approaching 3,000 people
watching here on YouTube. Over 500
people watching on TikTok. No, I ain't
going to hear him out. I ain't going to
hear him out. Poso, if if if you come
and you make an argument for Islam, make
sure it is right. Make sure you are
direct. Okay? Don't waste my time and
others here. I'm not the only one here.